le même même des plus petits casses de
de la maternelle même le cours
préparatoire tous à vos mots je trouve
que ça ça prend part à la vie puisque si
on n'était pas passé à la part le mode
kernel on se rend pas ici en ce moment
donc je pense que tu te réclames à
quelque chose pendant sa diffusion
quels sont vos toiles et les délais
qualité idéale d'un très bon connaisseur
qu'est-ce qui doit avoir comme qualité
il est sympathique
comment ne pas être trop sévère
votre passion de miel va bien expliqué
est ce que vous les jugez souvent aux
professeurs tout le monde pratique
normale et des fouets quand on change de
classe on s'aperçoit que ce n'était pas
si mauvais que ça moi je trouve que il
devrait étaient tous sévère ou pas
sévère parce que moi j'ai eu des
problèmes en mathématiques
j'avais un professeur qui n'a été assez
large l'année dernière puis cette année
on est tombé sur un professeur qui n'as
tu assez sec
alors on se disait ça yeux on eu bon en
maths on va ça va marcher comme sur des
roulettes ou et puis cette année ça n'a
pas marché c'est pour que ça va marcher
mais c'était plus difficile
est ce que tu penses de la mixité est ce
que tu es pauvre la mixité c'est la
meilleure des filles et les garçons dans
un ballet qu'il avait chez plon
c'est mieux d'être mélangés plutôt
d'avoir un groupe de filles deux garçons
- on est en commun ou kinoïde et le moi
je suis pour aussi parce que si on était
c'est pareil dans la vie actuelle
on doit rouler comme ça ferait toujours
des clubs à part des garçons avec les
garçons et les filles avec les femmes
alors je suis pour l'amour cité sacrée
des fois des disputes mais enfin souvent
c'est assez bien je trouve
la confrontation gars ont fui la
tendance un peu à trois pensées versant
supérieur enfin c'est ce que dans
certains domaines s'il faut ça partager
quoi certaines matières même extra
scolaires où les filles sont ils
meilleurs que les garçons comme ça je
trouve qu'il faut que ça se rafraîchir
d'émulation en classe d'avoir des idées
fixes moment ah oui
je tends c'est quand même mieux que ce
soit me mélanger des problèmes
différents sites et parce que ça dépend
de ton père avant la loi je crois que je
m'ennuierais tous ses fils je pense que
la mixité c'est une chose très bien que
nous évite d'avoir des contextes leur
fille c'est très bien l'enseignement de
maurice inscrits dans tout un système
d'éducation en quelque sorte c'est un
système de conditionnement
conditionnement à devenir plus tard
telle ou telle profession
ça s'inscrit dans ce système il ya toute
l'éducation les jouets les choses comme
ça ça ça tend à nous conditionner à
devenir plus tard pour les femmes mères
de famille les poupées les choses comme
ça éducation
comme on appelle ça
travaux manuels couture etc réservé aux
filles
ça s'inscrit dans dans tout ce système
là on est pas d'accord s'il comprend
bien avec l'enseignement pour vous
dispense non pour un enseignement de l
inde idéal devrait être axée sur la
personnalité des élèves aidés à
développer cette personnalité propre à
chaque élève
ce qui n'est pas le cas dans
l'enseignement en ce moment car on fait
apprendre aux élèves des choses qui
n'ont aucunement envie d'apprendre et
qui nous intéresse pas qu'est ce que
vous pensez du baccalauréat par exemple
une institution dépassée et sert plus à
grand chose maintenant parce que enfin
de plus en plus on va aller non pas
simplement parce qu'on a appris au lycée
lille dans les études et par le la
formation professionnelle plus qu'autre
chose choix que le baccalauréat sur ce
transfert ne sert plus à rien d'ailleurs
je sais pas s'il va rester encore
longtemps parce que je parlais de gauche
et plus quoi france à deux ans après ça
c'est encore l'histoire pour prolonger
des études parce qu'il n'ya pas assez de
place pour le travail et encore beaucoup
de chômage pour les jeunes en général
qui sortent d'un bac l'autre une
formation ils ont pas ils n'ont pas de
place enfin moi je vois des gens qui ont
une formation professionnelle et qui
trouvent pas de travail alors que les
études un fade
qu'est ce que vous pensez des
professeurs en général sont bien mal
moyens mais la plupart des professeurs
en général sont bon évidemment il y en
ad des moins bons
et en général ils sont bons il ya des
exceptions
la principale qualité d'un professeur ça
devrait être laquelle l'objectivité et
puis aussi de savoir parfaitement ce
dont ils parlent parce qu' il existe des
professeurs qui ne connaissent pas
parfaitement le
la matière qui qui doivent enseigner
mais comment pouvez-vous le business
vous mais ça se sent coincée quelque
chose qui ça doit dépendre de la
formation des professeurs ça se sent
aussi de la même manière quand un
professeur c'est des tas de choses
il est capable de nous répondre sur
n'importe quoi quand il n'est pas
capable de nous répondre si on importe
quoi touchant bien entendu à sa manière
sa matière là il ya des petites lacunes
à combler les siens iberia je pense que
le professeur pour enseigner
correctement doit connaître comme le
disait jean bernard la matière qu'ils
enseignent parfaitement et et aussi les
mais je pense bon un professeur qui vous
parle d'un de telles hauteurs bon et on
sent on sent qu'ils disent qu'ici la
thèse bien ses élèves automatiquement et
pas de problème quoi abane au moment où
toute la classe peut rester attentive
peux tu écoutais sens sans bouger toutes
les deux minutes et tout ça on mâchoire
ccc duo professeur donc aussi bien dans
du mauvais côté aussi donc si justement
la classe chahutent ou quoi mais il a
case à prendre car oui parce que si lui
ne s'est pas bien tu sais pas exercer la
profession mais c'est pas c'est pas de
la faute des élèves
oui d'autre part je dois insister sur le
fait que le professeur doit savoir et
doit être être conscient qu'il est
perfectible
parce que souvent des professeurs sont
imbus de leur personne et censure qu'ils
ont raison face aux élèves ça existe
toujours le chahut jeu
toujours et ça les manifestations de
quoi le chalut exactement maintenant là
votre âge par exemple on chahute
pourquoi dacourt inintéressant s'il
court captifs cavs ne captive pas les
élèves partir de ce moment-là de chahut
existe avancer c'est cela la principale
raison le coordinateur esprit on chérit
pas gratuitement
non je pense pas vous arrive d'être du
en méchant mais avec un professeur oui
certainement être soi même sans s'en
rendre compte
enfin moi j'estime que appartement où on
est prof on a voulu être prof et maya
aucune raison ne pas être dur il faut
quand même voir la réalité en face quoi
on est prêt il fait bien son travail ne
fait pas oui vous avez droit de la faire
sentir s'il ne la font pas bien oui
parfaitement
on parle de l'autodiscipline les élèves
disent ah oui c'est très chouette et
puissant même pas capable de l'appliquer
ça fait un petit peu rires aussi alors
la mixité oui ça c'est intéressant
les femmes réclament à leur émancipation
je pense qu'elle pourrait se faire tout
à fait naturellement
si on mixait les les deux sexes si vous
voulez ensemble dès le début la
maternelle on met des garçons et filles
ensemble l'école primaire d'un concert
on sait par tout le monde et puis
maintenant aussi un hold-up d'acier ma
troisième place à buffon par exemple ont
remis ensemble pour qu'à partir d'un
troisième après la seconde on les
recettes par à nouveau alors ya quelque
chose qui va pendant pourquoi mais
pourquoi vous voyez qu on vous sait pas
quand vous remet ensemble comme c'est
pas bon pardon pabu foncez c'est parce
qu'il ya un manque de place ça d'après
garçons d'accord ça c'est l'argument
d'administration a nice on a dit on
n'accepte plus les filles après ta
seconde parce que parce que les
sanitaires ne sont pas conçus pour voilà
on répète la nouvelle vient c'est vrai
ça fait 4 mètres sur les raisons
profondes
j'ai passé place paul et pour les
garçons ou quoi wen à bagheria dodier
l'odyssée pour filles dans le 15e bon ok
l'espace le garçon bon moi moi on
l'accord quoi ils ont peur plutôt qu'il
se passe des choses bizarres
enfin disons qu'il aurait sous leur
responsabilité
un problème que tu es est ce que vous
pensez justement pour m'exciter favorise
ces problèmes
non oui je pense comptera pas du tout la
mixité favorise ce problème étant donné
que façon ça arrivera bien un jour un
autre jeu une fois pourquoi on s'y
mettrait plutôt que plus tard dans
l'année que de toute façon c'est comme
ça on n'y peut rien et ça ne change rien
du tout à notre comportement nos
missions fait une synthèse de tout ce
que vous avez dit ce sera notre
conclusion là dessus vous pensez que on
al'impression finalement que tout ce qui
ne va pas c'est la faute de
l'administration des professeurs et
votre faute à vous allez très minime
finalement non ben oui
[Musique]